the loyal cats are really interesting
for a lot of reasons I love language and
i love the image that people have the
internet being a place where you go to
see cat pictures and from a bunch of
different web communities such as 4chan
and some of the other kind of
underground web communities people were
captioning cats with a text about what
they thought the cats would be saying
and you know it's kind of a funny little
stick like you have a you have a cat and
you know cats are great fodder for the
web because everybody you know we I have
a cat like you know that they're kind of
evil on the inside but they're also kind
of hapless and that combination of like
really diabolical but not able to do
anything about it is really great fodder
and then all the captions kind of
followed a pattern for how people were
doing the grammar or the speech of these
presumable cats talking and so I kind of
just made an observation this is really
consistent this is how language forms
you know and I'm very fortunate I I have
a good number of friends that are
linguists or you know that helped create
dictionaries and and so they know a lot
about etymology and out language
develops and I said you know is this
something like a you know a pidgin
language and they're like now this is
more of a Creole and you know Creole is
what one group of one language it uses
to kind of adapt their language to
another group can understand it I said
this is the language that cats are
speaking in hoping that humans will
understand them and so that idea of
taking these cat pictures lolcatz so
seriously i think really take a walk
take a lot of people's fancy it might be
the most popular thing i've ever written
you know i've been blogging 10 years and
i wrote about law cats and i tell you i
can go anywhere in the country almost
anywhere in the world and if i'm in a
group of people that know you know me
professionally and the first few minutes
somebody will bring up lolcatz and you
know if you got to be known for cat
pictures on the web that at least it's
the smart take on cat pictures on the
web I you know I love it I love the
web's culture i love how inventive
people are and coming up with new stuff
and they have fun with it and keep remix
again i hope that never ends
no I've had some fun over the years
online usually taking some little
obscure element of web culture or geek
culture and kind of taking it to you
know the outsiders and having some fun
with it I think I'm not at all
embarrassed about it like I like to have
fun I think you have to have a sense of
humor right you can't take yourself too
seriously I fear though you know one of
the things I did I work there's a an
offensive web site on the web called
goatse that a lot of geeks know it's a
it's a picture you literally don't want
to look directly at but somebody made a
non offensive t-shirt about it was just
kind of a joke and one of the classic
things you used to do on the web five or
ten years ago it was you would send
somebody a link to this image and they
click on it before they realized and
then they would you know yell at you for
doing it to them is just kind of a
harmless prank a lot like what
rickrolling became later although Rick
Astley is nowhere near as offensive and
so you know I had a shirt that had this
logo for it on it and when New York
Times wanted to do a story about
presenting your reputation online I wore
the shirt for their photo of me for the
story and it was one of those things
where I knew everybody on the web would
get it i knew the times probably
wouldn't maybe these days they would but
back then they didn't and so it was a
lot of fun what I fear is you know
people look at wikipedia and the first
couple Google results to decide who you
are and I think you know someday 50
years from now I'll die don't say which
we put on this guy's tombs down it's
going to be well he wore an offensive
t-shirt he wrote about law cats like
there's no you know it there there were
more substances things I've done in my
career but they they tend to get
overshadowed by the really fun once I
think there's worse things to be thought
of than somebody likes a good joke
you